en 1951 linda brown et écolières atopie
cas au kansas
elle habite tout près d'une école
qu'elle ne peut pas fréquenter parce
qu'elle est noire
cette école est réservé aux blancs ses
parents doivent s'inscrire à un autre
établissement à plus d'un kilomètre de
là un topic a comme dans d'autres villes
du kansas les écoles primaires sont
séparés cette ségrégation est la norme
dans 17 états du sud
le père de linda conteste cette loi il
n'est pas le seul des parents de trois
états se joignent à une plainte en
recours collectif la plainte est rejetée
en première instance mais elle poursuit
son chemin jusqu'à la cour suprême
il faudra deux ans à la cour pour rendre
sa décision qui tombe le 17 mai 1954
larry brown est historique à l'unanimité
les neuf juges décrète que la
ségrégation à l'école et est
inconstitutionnelle
il ordonne aux états d'y mettre fin mais
la cour en impose pas de délai et le
jugement suscite une forte opposition
dans le sud
il faudra des années pour que l'arbre en
soit appliquée ce n'est qu'en 1957 que
dix enfants noirs pourront s'inscrire
dans une école secondaire blanche
et en 1960 ruby bridges il deviendra la
première petite fille a fréquenté une
école primaire blanche la déségrégation
atteindra son sommet en 1988
cette année-là 45 % des étudiants
afro-américains fréquentait une école à
majorité blanche
depuis cette proportion n'a pas cessé de
décliner
il